hey what's up guys I'm Cedric the
Entertainer and I feel short and
indifferent sometimes sometimes angry
about being Conan's
friend let's go through those was the
first one short yes I was so surprised
at how tall you were the first time I
met you I know it shocked it just was
like what yeah you know it was supposed
to be no also uh people act like I've
been lying to them I never say anything
about my height but they act like no you
came across this so small on television
so small-minded and Petty think you had
really big desk when you think about it
yes you did you had made a choice of
being in the little chair for
Thanksgiving all right well I'm so glad
you're here because we have a lot to
talk about first of all you're a genius
cuz you named yourself Cedric the
Entertainer that is the smartest move
anyone's made in the history of show
business because no one can question it
it's like no it's on my tax for
I am the Entertainer let's go yeah let's
go you know what and it actually kind of
happened though it was weird it was
weird cuz another dude called me that
first and it was it was only because I
didn't have a lot of jokes I used to
sing a lot and and you know do poetry on
stage anything I could do to Philip the
time and so I just told dude don't call
me a comedian call me an Entertainer and
that's how it happen so and I just kept
the name from there but then like when I
first got to Hollywood they definitely
wanted me to change that that was like
you know all the agents is like no go by
your government name Cedric Schaefer no
it's not it's not Schaefer
guys you know I tagged you for a schaer
the minute you walked in I tagged you
for a
schaer I'm like like this guy's Jewish I
know it it's already been a hard time
finding my dad as it is but that
would no that would have been even more
of a challenge also I love I love like
you go to these people for Creative
advice and their advice is use your
government name yeah exactly what
talking about I think I wonder what Bono
would do you
know yeah Patty Ali want no one wants to
hear that gu hear Rock dude say hey
Patty give us another one give us
another one think about the Joshua Tree
uh but really like when you're out there
and and bored and living there in a that
version yeah you uh you know thing is
you are h seriously funny first time I
saw you and and you really came to my
notice was and I want to go back before
that but Kings of Comedy is when I felt
like who is this guy and I didn't know
and I thought that was such a great film
because uh it it featured you all so
brilliantly it showed that you are you
still are the kings of comedy it's
amazing it's a beautiful thing man that
was such a you what year was that was
that late '90s or early 2000s early
2000s we we started the tour in late 90s
it was so 98 was the first dates but we
didn't shoot the movie until like 01
right at the end of
2001 right in there and so you know fun
time man you know comedy was growing uh
you know the the idea that shows like de
Comedy Jam and started to really put
like black comedians in the in the
Forefront of uh like just having an
audience that was our very own so you
know when we by putting us all together
we were able to do Arenas and it was a
few people that done you know of course
Dice and and Eddie Murphy I think Martin
had done Arena tours but nobody kind of
did it like this you know like a like
Coachella like you know you got a lot of
your favorites there at one night and so
that that was fun that was Rockstar
stuff man we we had a blast on that tour
I also think it it it blew up awareness
this that that needed to happen it blew
up awareness in a really beautiful way
that uh that you guys are a force you
you know what I mean that that and uh
it's you weren't trying to you weren't
trying to get other people into the tent
you were saying we don't that we
don't need that we're this is what we do
we're hilarious and uh and look at this
whole world that follows us and you
should be here too I remember being
thinking Jesus Christ these guys are a
phenomenon yeah I think you know you're
right and I think that was really what
what became a catalyst to opening up you
know of course we had like um you know
you know the networks with like WB and
UPN starting to you know like create
shows uh for uh you know like
predominantly African-American families
but it definitely opened up this idea
like comedy is not like the the the the
evening at The Improv way which was the
only way you can get on television right
if back then you do evening at The
Improv and try to get picked to be on
Carson or Leno or something like that
and then you know you you you came along
at a time when it was far you know you
were one of us that's what makes you
cool that's what everybody goes
everybody you know I'm just saying in
the hood everybody goes trust me
everybody goes oh Conan O'Brien he's one
of us he's one of us oh I swear to God I
get that all the time don't laugh Sona I
get that all the
time when I go to the hood when I go to
the hood people are like oh good you're
back in the hood yeah you're back and
everybody's like yo I mean I go to
barber shop you see con and L Le I'm
like yeah man that's my that's my NW
yeah come on Sona how many times have
you been looking for me and I've been at
the barber shop oh yeah oh so many Sho
just shooting the hanging out
getting a nice fade yeah I'm
sorry yes that's true I need a fade I
need a fade so badly you should go like
to Philadelphia where they do the
Linings where they line up you you
haven't had facial hair in a long time
though I shaved it off long yeah I did I
had a beard for a while and then uh and
then I shaved it uh will Ferell actually
said shave it or I'm coming on the show
and I'll shave it and I didn't shave it
so he came on the show brought a barber
chair and shaved me and it was hilarious
and then I thought once will Ferell
shaves you you can't go back no that's
it that's it so I was done after
that